alright so the DC Cinematic Universe
movies are pretty divisive among fans
does that divisive nature carry over to
the DC animated features well yeah The
Killing Joke so The Killing Joke is an
animated feature based on the acclaimed
graphic novel by Alan Moore that
ultimately revolves around the Joker and
the Joker has one goal he wants to prove
that a normal guy can go crazy under the
right circumstances of one bad day and
that's what half of this movie is about
first of all what I liked about this
whole thing I loved the fact that Kevin
Conroy and Mark Hamill came back to
reprise their roles as Batman and the
Joker I do hearing Mark Hamill deliver
Alan Moore's dialogue is pretty sweet
it's a very dark brooding [ __ ]
version of the Joker and I'm glad they
got Mark Hamill for it and it is ballsy
with some of the disturbing imagery in
it and I do love the fact that there are
parts in here dialogue shots visual
representation you're like that's pulled
from Alan hoarse The Killing Joke I
suppose when you're translating it you
should be accurate or just it's always
great to see when people are accurate
that said some of the animation was a
little wonky I thought the Joker looked
fine Batman's suit his cowl looked a
little strange like it doesn't go up
like Batman ears just like he has his
head and then it kind of like bows out
like double horns or something and one
of my fears about The Killing Joke came
true and that is like everyone's like oh
it's rated R oh my god you can't believe
it's rated R and I was thinking well if
they're accurately gonna represent it I
don't know how it's rated R and I had
this fear that it was going to be like
the conjuring was rated R because it was
too scary but in the end it's a pg-13
movie that was rated R because it's cool
to be rated R and it got people talking
about it exactly what this is there is
nothing beyond pg-13 in this entire
thing and it just always pisses me off
when people have to make things rated R
because it's edgy and cool it's like but
that's not a representation of what it
is it's not rated R they don't say [ __ ]
there's not rated R blood there's a sex
scene just cuts away from the sex scene
I don't require animated titties in my
face I'm just saying if you're gonna
make it read it are why not just do read
it R that's the thing that pissed some
people off in the first 30 minutes of
this movie there's this whole Batgirl
setup because they have to get you to
care about Batgirl before the Joker the
shooter and paralyzes her and her and
Batman [ __ ] on the roof of this building
and it pissed a lot of people off my
Twitter was blown up like this is
[ __ ] that doesn't even make me mad I
didn't care about that there are other
bits of Batman lawrence storytelling
that do imply insinuate and say that
man and batgirl did have a pass it's not
the first time I've seen that so I just
didn't care but I cared about in fact
the first 30 minutes of this movie are
useless I don't mean kind of useless in
the way that it could have been better
if they tweak this and tweak that no I'm
saying [ __ ] useless didn't need to
happen if you're going to do setup have
setup that has anything to do with the
Joker that would have been better if you
want us to care about Batgirl more have
Batgirl on Batman chasing down the Joker
that capture a minute goes like a year
later or something like that then he
escapes and then he does his Killing
Joke [ __ ] you want set up do set up this
relevant to the rest of the movie this
is just some mobster dude has a crush on
Batgirl it's dumb as [ __ ] the first 30
minutes of The Killing Joke was like a
filler episode of Batman animated series
in fact if I didn't physically
personally put in the disc I wouldn't
have known it was actually the killing
Joker you poor bastards who saw it in
the theaters I'm sure you were like I
think there's been a mistake we're
watching the wrong Batman film seriously
it's about 28 minutes long skip about 29
minutes into the killing joke and then
start it out there you'll start out with
The Killing Joke stuff in that this
movie would have been a pretty solid 45
minutes Tim without the 30 minute
dissertation of nonsense that they
wanted to show it in some theaters to
fathom events and whatnot so they in
order to have people pay to watch it in
theaters you have to have this certain
amount of time it's about an hour and 15
minutes maybe 45 minutes just I guess
wouldn't have been enough and it would
have made it better and it's just that's
what irritates me about it is that they
wanted to make more money so in order to
have this theatrical release which I
guess the pre-sales totally crushed you
had to compromise the movie as a whole I
guess they got their money back for
everybody who's disappointed in this
thing the ending I'm iffy on i flow and
a bond I'm about to spoil anything for
you sorry about that but spoiler warning
in the end of this story it ends
accurate to the graphic novel where the
Joker tells a joke and Batman and Joker
share a laugh together and I hated it
when I read it there is a fan theory
that Batman actually kills the Joker and
there you see his arm going into him and
it looks like it might be might be
stabbing him but Alan Moore was like nah
he's not he's just laughing with him and
I hate that Alan Moore wrote that to be
the Joker shot and paralyzed one of
Batman's friends and colleagues he
tortured another friend and colleague
Jim Gordon in the end Batman shares a
laugh with this [ __ ] I just don't buy
that I hate that interpretation of the
end but this animated version does play
to the theory that Batman might kill the
Joker you see them both laughing you
hear them both laughing then the camera
pans down and you don't hear the Joker
laughing anymore you just hear Batman
I think only Batman so it was really the
first time I was like wait is he did he
kill it like you just vision Batman
laughing while he's strangling the Joker
the Joker can't breathe so he can't
laugh anymore so how it was originally
written intended by Alan Moore I didn't
like that version of the ending where
Batman shares a laugh at the Joker so I
choose to believe Batman cracked in a
joker one because I'm a dick and as cool
as I think that is I find it more
heartbreaking that the first 30 minutes
of this entire film is just completely
compromised by that filler [ __ ] guys in
the end about 45 minutes of The Killing
Joke was pretty sways gift the first 30
minutes go right to the Killing Joke
stuff you'll actually have a pretty good
representation of what The Killing Joke
actually is voiced by Mark Hamill and
Kevin Conroy that is always great when
you have 30 minutes of this hour and 15
minute long animated film they'd be
completely useless it's just compromises
the entire thing it's better more
financially efficient more enjoyable to
just pick up the Killing Joke and read
it bummer enough this is a huge
disappointment I'm going to say Batman
The Killing Joke would probably be a
better time if you were drunk yeah now
it's a party argh you know it's you can
be sober if you just skip the first 30
minutes fair point drunk me all right
guys so Batman The Killing Joke have you
seen it what did you think about it or
did you read it how do you think you
compared how do you think they compare
to each other whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more